is it better to work in a mindless job
and make money or is it better to follow
your passion and possibly make less
money
hmm I definitely think the best thing to
do is work at a job that you're
passionate about and make a lot of money
that's that's the best thing to do I do
know that one that's not always possible
and here's something you got to be
careful of have you ever heard people
talk about making your hobby your job
right and generally that's like oh if I
make my hobby my job then I'll enjoy my
job right there's another way of looking
at it if you make your hobby your job
you won't like your hobby anymore yeah
that's another way of looking at that so
it depends on what kind of like a
jiu-jitsu instructor yeah right hey I'll
just open my own school and then I'll
just I'll just get to do what I love all
day long you talk to a lot of jiu-jitsu
instructors after six years they don't
even like going to the academy they
don't want to go to the Academy anymore
cuz it's all ah yeah I don't wanna deal
what another white belt how to do an
armlock they're over it so that's not
necessarily the best thing to make what
you're passionate about and there's some
people that teach you to every single
day and they love it and that's awesome
and so they've they've won right because
they're making money they're doing their
have a good livelihood and they enjoy
doing it so yeah but my goal would be to
do something that I'm passionate about
at the same time you got to set yourself
up so that you're not stuck without any
money right because passion doesn't pay
the rent I'll tell you an example of
this Greg train sure years ago Greg
train said to me hey here's my options I
can like kind of scrape by teach
wrestling teach some jujitsu and train
to fight or I can guy got accepted into
this program to be an x-ray technician
and he asked me he's like what do you
what do you think I should do this or a
long time ago it's probably 10 or 12
years ago maybe even longer hmm anyways
he asked me and I said listen how many
hours a day do you want
train and I said how many hours day can
you train any Zack I don't know maybe 3
or 4 hours day ok so if you want to do
this 3 or 4 hours a day and you're not
gonna make any money what are you gonna
do with the other
whatever 20 hours a day yeah you could
actually build a career and make real
money doing the xray thing and then you
could still easily because you work 8
hours a day I was like I was like Greg I
work 12 hours a day I work 14 hours a
day I'm still here training mm-hmm you
can work an eight-hour day and still
train and you can train four hours a day
and you can be fine
and you'll have money you don't have to
worry about paying the rent you won't
have to be able to buy you know nice
things you'll have medical insurance all
those things and he made the decision to
go to x-ray school and he ended up doing
great in jiu-jitsu and doing great in
fighting and he ended up getting some
injuries that were like if he would have
just been a fighter
they would have been really problematic
because you know he couldn't fight for a
long time he so that's the kind of
that's the kind of judgment call Yeah
right you can make um now what what this
question is saying though is can you do
something will you make a little bit
less but you're passionate about that's
that's pretty easy call as far as I'm
concerned if you just make a little bit
less but you love doing it well that's
kind of a no-brainer yeah right mmm
isn't it now you got to ask yourself
where does that put you in the future
and then you gotta ask yourself on the
other side is could you do this job that
you don't really like for long enough
that you could make a difference like
you could do this job that you don't
like in y'all zone you got a down
payment for a house and then you go buy
a house you see what I'm saying
yeah so that's that's not a bad movie a
bad move either but you could also this
is where people trap themselves they
have the job that they don't like
they're making a little bit more money
and instead of investing towards getting
out of that job and setting themselves
up so where they can do something that
they are professional what they do is
they expand their lifestyle yeah that's
the big mistake they
ban their lifestyle and all of a sudden
you know they're making $100,000 a year
at this job that they don't really like
the other job they were gonna get
$75,000 a year and that that's not bad
right I would probably go for the thing
that I really like doing if it's a
difference of $25,000 that's kind of a
no-brainer to me what does the person do
they say okay well I'll just stay in
this job so I can make enough money to
get a down payment on the house and then
what do they do they buy a new car yeah
they go out to dinner every night they
spend that extra twenty five thousand
that they could be putting into saving
up for downpayment they spend it on
stuff that they don't need to end up
with a hundred and ten thousand dollar
lifestyle while they're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year and they
actually go into debt and now they're
further away from the job that they
wanted yeah so I guess the answer here
is and I've said this before come up
with an exit strategy with contingencies
if things go wrong and then plan save
prepare and then execute sounds like a
good plan good take on it sounds like
the I found that when you make your
hobby your career a lot of times like
when you have fantasies about doing your
hobby as a career let's say I'm a
photographer right that's a big that's a
common one and they'll be like okay cuz
I like taking pictures I like you know I
don't know maybe traveling or I don't
know whatever whatever I like taking
pictures of I like that kind of subject
- oh but so a lot of things when you're
you know a creative person or you you're
into let's say you make baskets right
you make the awesome baskets but to make
it your career a lot of the times it
comes with like yeah 50% if not a
hundred percent additional of chores and
tasks but running that business yeah I
was gonna say yeah you like making
baskets oh yeah cool and what you end up
doing is making thousands of the same
baskets but they're green with the
Easter Bunny in it and that's what your
job is to weave that basket over over
again everything that you're doing it
for is now gone yeah and and guess what
you have to do it and you have to do you
have to like as a hobby that's kind of
in my opinion pretty much the one of the
two things that make
be so great is because it's fun to do
and you do whatever you want as long as
you have the time as long as you you do
whatever you like if you don't feel like
do it like if you don't feel like
golfing tomorrow you yeah oh you don't
feel like golf I know are you gonna go
no you don't have to but if you love
making baskets and you don't feel like
it and you're like guess what you gotta
make a thousand of those I know you
don't feel like even making one you
gotta make a thousand now or make sure
they're done or something I mean you're
like man I used to love this thing now I
don't really like it cuz all this
pressure which had nothing to do with my
hobby by the way nothing now it has
everything to do with my hobby now you
got now I have people calling me saying
hey where's my basket hey I'm the basket
maker I say when the basket gets me kind
of thing that's gone so yeah so you
don't really like it and so yeah you got
the repetitiveness the the the like we
call a control lack of control the
pressure fresh and then that's not to
mention like the day-to-day chores that
allow your hobby activity to be a
business or career or whatever man it's
a lot like freaking taxes taxes doing oh
yeah man you know like when you work it
like a job and the taxes are just taken
out all this stuff but man you're
weaving baskets you know in your in your
new garage or whatever man you get your
taxes all this there's just a lot more
to it we're all huge over from hobby to
career yeah that's true so that's my my
shout out to my tax guy man he rocks so
hard is the best guy ever yeah yeah so
there's that and then but yeah if you're
prepared for that though if you're
totally prepared for that or if you kind
of like business you know that part of
it because there's a lot of chores in
business yeah and if you like that stuff
oh man
that can be good but yeah oh and here's
the thing too about when you get a good
job I'm not a good job at a high paying
job but you don't like it this is why
this is what I think he do man I don't
think I've ever had a junk job that paid
a lot you just said junk low-paying jobs
yes yes yes for sure um so okay I wake
up I drag myself to my job
right drag myself and then I'm can't
wait to get home and get home and get
that paycheck after a week two weeks or
whatever get that huge paycheck and then
I gotta drag myself to my job again and
I go home and I can let me breathe so
basically your day-to-day for that jump
job is so jump I need something any
pleasure I need some pleasure in my life
by that cool new car so now oh yeah I'll
drag myself to my job but at least I'm
rolling in that new nice new car or but
eventually you trap yourself with that
car that car's a trap because that
becomes the focus a lot of the times
yeah you know like to make up and I
believe so this is an interesting thing
I've thought about people like to make
things people like to make things I
could say it's it's a good feeling to
make something to create something and I
think a lot of the consumer attitude
comes from the fact that look I don't
have time to go and build a desk hmm and
I wish I did have time to go build a
desk but I'll just go click on this
button and the desk will show up my
house and it's kind of like I created
something la la there it is
and and that gives you that but the
thing is it's a it's a short-term
gratification yeah and that's why it
keeps going cuz you go okay I really
like to make a desk but I'm just gonna
buy this one or I'd really like to you
know what I'd love to do is just is just
completely refurbish an old car oh I
can't do that but guess what I can I can
just buy a new car and then I'm wrong
and it feels good for a minute but you
don't get the pure you don't get the
deep satisfaction that you would have
gotten had you refurbished the car yeah
so you get you trap yourself so keep
your spending in check this is another
part of this whole deal
keys bending and check but that spending
feels so good and then you know like it
depends because there's some times when
you don't have a lot of money spending
hurts you know it hurts when you're like
I can't separate myself from this money
yeah and you have you have a different
mindset I think but I think like a your
average person me included it's like the
the spending hurts when you spend spend
on stuff you need rather than what you
like want you know I'm so backwards
thing oh yeah that's so very time but
it's a short-term thing for sure it's
like the immediate like satisfaction is
like when you got a pay let's say you
don't really have dental insurance right
or let's say you do but you still
whatever you gotta spend your money on
that yeah say it's $1,000 and you have
1500 dollars in your bank account
so it doesn't feel good to spend on
dental but it would have felt good to
buy a new plasma screen oh man you could
watch the US when that plasma TV comes
in you're like oh my gosh you can't wait
to hook this up this thing is awesome
I'll even put it on my credit card and
pay for that thing over the next 12
months 50% interest on this thing I'll
do that no problem because of that
pleasure of getting it but Oh dental you
mean this toothache will go away this
toothache that's causing me a migraine
will go away and then I got you know
then when it's time to pay that bill
it's hard man
you don't really want it it's weird Chad
it's backwards though
alright well like I said come up with a
plan come up with an exit strategy with
contingencies and then save you money
and execute get sewn